hello bye-bye nobody seems to want to be
my friend anymore
that they thought that whoa whoa hello
everybody's my friend now except for you
you go away oh this looks diabolical and
evil and I love it cool what did that do
oh hello hi Oh Bonnie hey I got a party
for you we got invited into a very very
very special party that you're just
gonna love come on Bonnie I need your
expertise on the party advice mind your
head
watch out excuse me pardon coming
through me and Bonnie together forever
we're gonna be friends for all eternity
we're gonna be friends for so long
you're gonna love it
bonnie bonnie bonnie bonnie bonnie i
need you for something wow oh my god oh
right good
and I still got Bonnie hey Bonnie are
you doing Bonnie you look good come with
me Bonnie we're gonna go on an adventure
again except this time I have some sort
of special powers hey Bonnie do that
dance heal up for me are you on some do
wow you guys are great oh you guys are
great I love you I love you I love you I
love you oh yeah
yeah oh yeah okay okay thank you yeah
all right Bonnie come with me are you
laughs oh darn
still hurt it still hurts still hurt Oh
Bonnie Bonnie don't you run away from me
ow
hey everybody what are you protesting
over here oh it sounds great I think
I'll join you hey come here come on come
on I want to tell you something
why don't you run away from me don't you
run away from Barney either hey hey hey
buddy hey buddy what's crying about no
more tears now only happiness can't run
away from the body ball well that sucks
what I was going on over there
wonder if this seems problematic at all
wow this is slightly disturbing I'm
totally sure what's going on here
everybody happy
what's everybody happy with what's going
on here everybody happy everybody happy
hi buddy hi you don't wanna be my friend
I'm gonna have to show you a thing or
two
come on Oh God I did something I don't
goof still get Barney okay let's think
I've broken even harder than I have
before already then I wonder when this
is gonna end
Bonnie and I are just dancing as we're
going along into the sky it's like that
dance of the Dragons or something like
that Wow good golly only me would be
stupid of to be able to do this hey
what's that ow
okay Bonnie come over here we got
something see Bonnie check it out for me
buddy go on - go Bonnie you're such a
kidder get in the hole
Wow I don't know what's going on what
the hell did I get big come on big goat
Bonnie what happen to you Bonnie
did you lose weight Bonnie Bonnie I know
things have changed between us but we're
still the same I still love you just for
who you are finally we need a few more
friends sorry to say you're not enough
for me anymore I'm a big goat now the
big goat sings hey buddy
I did have it again wow that would be
like with the jetpack on honey we're
gonna go places together what do you
mean you don't like me anymore Bonnie
get back here
Bonnie get back here I'm gonna make you
like me we're gonna like me whether you
like me or not
I know that we're really close friends
and all but you'd be honest with me if
you thought I was turning into some
diabolical demon goat would you ow ow oh
no not again
Oh bonnie bonnie bonnie we got a problem
bonnie bonnie bonnie do something buddy
Bonnie we need friends Bonnie we need
friends
buddy yeah okay
that's not good okay this is slightly
disturbing and our life seems to be that
we're never gonna come down now so how
about about Bonnie we follow now okay
somehow we seem to have gotten out of
sync here Wow a buddy of every person
that's been playing this game I think I
broke tit the most hi wanna be my friend
okay we seem to be making our descent
here Bonnie if you just fasten your
seatbelt for a few seconds we'll be on
the ground sure
Bonnie listen to me Ted because I'm a
horrible dog I'm not again Bonnie you've
changed you really changed hi okay I
don't think this is beneficial to my
situation here bonnie bonnie where'd you
go ah
Bonnie Bonnie are you here anymore
I lost Bonnie I don't know what I'm
gonna do with my life
it's just not the same without body what
are we gonna do you want to be my new
Vlad hi you want to be my new friend oh
god damn it hello hi come back here
no you can't run away from me oh hi what
the hell did I just do red isn't quite
okay hello Oh Howie
okay this hurts this hurts a lot this is
quite painful this is indeed quite
painful I wonder when this organ is
gonna stop okay I'm caught on the road
here yeah that looks pretty painful
what's going on okay it happened again
what happened the can of Bonnie this
time you're not under here with me
Bonni Bonni come back here no no baby
please oh thank you I think is this
really not gonna work out what is it
about me you wanted